die 16-jährige sin überquert am 7 mai
mit ihrem fahrrad ein bahnübergang am
frankfurter stadtteil nied die schranken
sind oben und dann kommt es zu einem
schrecklichen unglück eine regionalbahn
rast auf dem bahnübergang zu derart
fasziniert auf ihrem fahrrad einen
weiteren fahrradfahrer und eine
autofahrerin
juni stirbt bei dem horror-crash wegen
einer technischen panne an den schranken
an seit jahren geht es darum wenn
irgendwelche pläne vorgelegt und
irgendwas verschoben und dann wird was
gebracht aber es ist einfach nichts
passiert und das ist erst so so so was
kommen musste dass ich meine schwester
genommen wurde durch durch speichern ist
durch was also ist
ich möchte auch hier niemandem die
schuld geben weil die sache ist ich
möchte einfach dass das aufgeklärt wird
nach diesem entsetzlichen unfall kommt
es jetzt wieder zu einer technischen
panne todes schranke donnerstagabend
gegen 19 uhr 20 nähert sich ein zug den
bahnübergang drei franken gehen runter
eine bleibt oben als der zug heran rast
der bahnwärter bemerkt die gefahren
meldet die störung während der
heranfahrenden zug zum stoppen kommt
sich hat der bahn werte den bahnübergang
laut der deutschen bahn weil die
schranke blockiert nur mit glück konnte
dieses mal ein unglück verhindert werden